[Music]
hi my name is Marsh Gardner I'm a
product manager for Google I tend to
work on happy G's developer portals and
Google Cloud endpoints portals as well I
also work on our open API based tooling
and represent Google on the governing
board for the open API initiative and
share the marketing group and serve on
the technical steering committee that
guides the evolution of the spec just
reminder this is better API design with
open API this is an intro level
discussion we're not gonna get deep into
the weeds on how the specification works
but we will talk about specs a lot in
general we're going to cover four areas
why not give you a bit of a background
on open API to will review
specifications and how they work
throughout the API lifecycle three we'll
cover some basic API design principles
and that will set us up to combine all
this all of these so that we can talk
about how open API has opinions guide
somewhat API design and the choices you
have to make there's a spoiler open API
is not going to magically make your API
awesome but it can help and hopefully by
the end of this you have a bit of an
understanding about how that helps and
why it matters who here uses open API
and their organisations today great
who's thinking about using open API good
who here still calls it swagger be
honest let's see the hands all right
okay well it's mine with my marketing
hat on for open API one of our
challenges is to get people to use the
name open API when referring to the
specification swagger still means the
tools and it that is still a perfectly
appropriate way to talk about the
tooling that SmartBear oversees but the
specification it's important that we use
the right name because this is an
industry format an industry standard but
behavior change is hard the good news is
those were fewer hands than last year
by percentages so I think we're making
progress
so briefly to set the stage before we
had this thing called swagger the state
of the art back in 2010 was still waddle
the web application description language
and wisdom for soap api's they've been
around a while and they were pretty
successful but they were also xml-based
formats and we saw it began to see the
rise of because of JSON and JavaScript
we began to see the rise of JSON based
API is over HTTP and it kind of sucked
to describe JSON based API as using XML
and in 2010 we had a couple of us a
pitch he took note of a new API
documentation approach that a company
called word Nick was pioneering for
their own api's and we thought it was
pretty cool so we reached out to them
which began a conversation and an Apogee
office about whether they would be
interested in Creative Commons licensing
the look and feel of their API
documentation and to our surprise they
said actually we're thinking of open
sourcing all of our tools we thought
that sounded pretty great and we talked
and laughed about how much it sucked to
describe JSON based api's with XML and I
think was Zeke who said why waddle when
you can swagger and people laughed and
thought that was funny and then someone
said actually I'd make a great name and
and so we began word Nick had created
all of these tools for to serve their
own needs and so in the beginning for
instance the description format that
they've created didn't have you couldn't
specify how you would do authentication
obviously other people needed that and
so as the community began to participate
this the format began to become more
descriptive it was also very much
bottom-up it was one company trying to
solve their own problems with software
and it wasn't a vendor saying I think
everyone should do it this way or a
consortium saying hey everybody like so
said a real authenticity about it was
solving real problems for real people
and it grew
organically over the next few years and
then in 2014 that was that about the
time where we were at Apogee getting
kind of tired of using wattle as our
preferred format and we took a survey to
see how the API description landscape
looked we still really liked what
swagger was doing and so we approached
Tony and suggested perhaps it was time
to consider a major revision to the spec
and that kicked off a working group it
introduced things like the yamo format
of at the time swagger eight swagger
specifications it did things like it
added a single file expression of a spec
before that you there was a mother's a
bastardized version you could do that
was embarrassing there it was really
multi file format and that turned out to
be a pain when you wanted to do things
like create an editor to make it easy to
create a spec in a browser it also added
things we call them at the time of
vendor extensions those would be renamed
specification extensions later but
really it's because we were realizing
that as providers we needed a way to mix
in a bunch of implementation details so
that's an important piece here is that
the swagger specification guru is really
as a way to document the contract for
clients but there's this interesting
tension between the fact that you know
while its client first it's also really
useful to the server side and how
providers are describing their own
services for their own needs in the back
I'm going to talk about that a bit more
later and we began to see with the 2.0
spec it's like the world was waiting for
it and I'll show you that in a slide in
a second it began to take off it also
became more important to get it into a
neutrally governed foundation and along
the way word NIC sold some of its
interests in swagger to to a smart bear
and some of its other technology is to
NDN and it became even more important
that if this is going to be an energy
standard it had to have neutral
governance and so the open API
initiative was founded the spec was
contributed by smart bear and all of
that led to figuring out the right
structure and organization for how we
would evolve the spec and we had the
that all led to the open API version 3
specification which took a lot longer
than anybody had planned
it was it took us a lot of time that was
released about a year ago and since then
we've seen tooling adopting it and it's
starting to get some pretty good
momentum around it this is why you can
see in 2014 when the when we started the
working group that's when interest began
to really take off
and it just it continued to accelerate
as we added the neutral governance model
around all of this it's like the world
was waiting for this and I stopped
tracking these numbers this is the Stack
Overflow tag trends for the various
formats of the note that you know as of
2017 and open API just continue to
accelerate and part of that is because
of this governance model so for those of
you who really interested you can go
read all about how the inner workings of
this happen but it's pretty interesting
I've never gone through this process
before how do you take this open source
project and make it a safe space for
lots of people to participate in and
that means doing things like
incorporating and making sure that in
everyone's assets are properly protected
and there's a level playing field for
folks it's pretty much doing stuff and
so we became a project of the Linux
Foundation and continue to this day
under their auspices and and we have all
of these guidelines and charters and you
know if you're really excited about this
you can read this one open API is that
org we grew from an original founding
members of nine we're now at I think 32
that's a pretty impressive collection of
logos that are these are all the members
in the open API initiative everything
from big Salesforce Google IBM Microsoft
down to small players who were focused
more on narrow sections of tooling but
it's pretty robust and it continues to
grow the reason why all these people
came together to work on this is because
having a common industry format to
describe api's is really important to a
lot of people into the industry as a
whole and this is why I said earlier
using the specification name open API
really does matter it's important that
that this thing be able to live on its
own and I think it's been doing great we
have more work to do
the specification itself evolves and is
maintained on github so if you if you
want to read through the specification
or participate or ask questions or file
issues this is a great place to go and
all of this is guided by the technical
steering committee we started as six
shrank down to four and we're back up to
six again we we meet once a week in
general for about an hour and a half
that's an open meeting except when we
have to deal with internal governance
issues these happen on Thursdays and
they're open to anyone you can actually
find the calendar through the github
repo we have all this documented and how
you can participate in the development
guidelines etc that's me I was I thought
was really cool in 2000 what 2007 to be
trapped inside an iPhone and I just
haven't updated my logo yet laughter um
so the purpose of this body is really to
govern the spec it's important to
consider the birding burden on tooling
authors when you're making changes to
the spec because anytime you add
something it's more work for people to
do or if you'd make a change and now
things are incompatible and so you know
it really the way the spec involves is
by the community needs but someone has
to make sure that it's evolving at the
right pace and that's what we do and it
but also you know it's a work like
writing for requests to make changes to
the specification clarifying things
along the way if you get excited about
API description formats you should come
talk to us and join right now we're
meeting on Thursdays in the morning so
we've had the 3.0 spec out for a year
and we've spent some of that time
thinking about how do you better involve
the community how to have clear
practices and guidelines for
participation but we also have a big
list of possibilities and we've spent a
lot of the last few months talking about
these things and I promised earlier I
wouldn't dig too deep into the
specification but these are the kinds of
things that were thinking about and this
is really what we need input from the
community for so again things like Reid
groups that's the idea that you could
define things and refer back to them
with have being able to write less
boilerplate over and over things like
alternative schemas if you don't want to
use json schema or even if you want to
use a newer version of json schema than
the one we support officially those are
things that we're considering we've
talked about adding multi segment paths
or a compaction i'm super excited about
overlays that's the idea that you could
separate some of the implementation
concerns from the specification itself
so rather than mixing in all of your
specification extension extensions as a
those implementation level details to be
able to have a separate file you could
think of as a layer on top and you would
merge those down those so again I would
encourage anybody who's interested in
these things to please participate it's
the community involvement that makes us
move these are the various ways you can
contribute so I would recommend visiting
the project on github there are issues
you could file or participate in pull
requests we have lots of passionate
arguments about things I would recommend
reading the development guidelines so
you apply your changes against the right
branch that kind of thing
we have that weekly conference call that
I mentioned we have meetups and if you
could want to join them or even host
them you should please get in touch with
us the easiest way to do that is via
open API spec on Twitter or that's
probably the easiest way to quickly
reach out to us but things look pretty
good and please participate okay part
two specifications in the API life cycle
so contracts when we open API is really
a contract based approach to things and
and really this is an agreement between
the client on the server so the server
says hey this is the way I want people
to talk to me and if you talk to me I
can promise that I'm going to be
somewhat stable and be around for a
while and the clients like hey that's
cool and so you know the register an
application and you are able to make
requests against that but I really do
think of it as like this formal contract
an agreement between these two sides I'm
ask you to imagination
this is as you can tell on the style of
Homer Simpson but legal would not let me
use summers
in my slides 'mentally substitute this
with Homer Simpson because I apparently
that's okay but sweet sweet declarative
compile-time contracts this is how I
that mean literally imagine myself as
Homer Simpson when I think about open
API in this way what it is is I love
that you're so declared you can
understand all the various capabilities
of an API it's very declarative and what
I mean by compile time is that as you
build your application the interface is
hardened it's unlike this you pair this
to things like hateoas hypertext as a
engine of application state where the
client can only do what the server says
is allowable from the state that you're
in this is much more declarative and you
can think of it as you know slices of
functionality that you can expect will
work in this way consistently a contract
defines the boundary of responsibilities
and they're great because this formal
agreement lets the client the server
teams understand the expected behaviors
so that I know what to expect
back when I ask you in this way there
have been other contracts has been
around for a long time we had we already
mentioned wisdom and wobble you know
before that we had things like CORBA and
we've had other contracts as well there
are different flavors I'm going to
mention hey toss before graph QL but you
know what I like about open API as I
mentioned is declarative nature and as I
mentioned earlier it it really grew out
of putting the client first what is it
that people are going to know in order
to be able to call my API um
Google doesn't use open API for its own
api's why
Google runs things that really big scale
and Google needs to have a binary based
format and so they have something they
use proto buffers and they have open
source something called G RPC and if you
come in within a couple orders of
magnitude of Google scale you might
consider it to but we also recognize
that exposing our API is with JSON
flavors is important so we have a
gateway that sits in front and it
basically takes that G RPC and exposes
it as JSON over HTTP and can be
expressed most of our EPS can be
expressed as open API in that way
the way I think about this is that if if
you like contracts and you've got scale
problems G RPC is a great fit if you
have adoption problems I would go with
open API if any of you have attended any
of appaji sessions before you've
probably seen a slide like this that is
how we think about the API lifecycle in
general the core lifecycle being those
icons in the center and this covers a
lot and if you look at kin lay in the
API evangelist site he's got pretty
similar lists I mean this is the API
management's been around for a while
these categories are pretty good no no
sorry it looks like people want pictures
all look wait one second three two one
good okay because I want to focus on
just the core lifecycle bits so you know
this is everything from imagining and
designing your API is through deploying
publishing and maintaining those
analyzing that traffic and how you then
maintain it over time protect against
threats real-time monitoring but what's
interesting to me is how many of these
stages are better informed by
specifications so they add value in lots
of different stages of the lifecycle and
I'll walk you through a couple of these
just to give you a flavor of what that
is documentation is the most obvious one
for many years people thought swagger
was swagger UI just because they'd see
this they'd see the documentation and
think that was it it was really a much
deeper and layered system but specs
driving documentation is the number one
reason that gets people to write
specification than my specifications of
my experience it everyone understands
that in order for a developer to consume
your API they have to understand how it
works they need documentation
maintaining documentation is a pain
and doing that by hand is kind of even
worse and whether you treat your API
specifications as truth or possible
truth and what I mean by that is say
you're generating your API
specifications from annotations and your
source code you can consider that to be
truth more or less if you write that
description and maintain it out-of-band
it is a description of a possible truth
it's still it may be just as true as the
ones driven from annotations but there's
a in in the case where you're writing it
out-of-band that's where you may want to
do automated tests to make sure that
your specification stays in fact in line
with what you're actually exposing with
your API so spec starting documentation
is the single biggest reason to use an
open API spec today but there are lots
of others so we use specs this is in a
pudgy edge when you go to create a proxy
which you do essentially in order to be
able to attach policies to control as a
part of API management how you control
traffic and access to the services that
you're offering if you have described
your API use an OPA using open API we
can use that information to help you
figure out how to manage your API so it
specs also can inform implementations
you may generate code on the back end
whether it's stubs or whether it's
something more sophisticated specs can
drive mocks this one seems obvious and
in many ways but it's surprising how few
organizations take advantage of it the
nice thing about driving mocks is it
lets you start building your client in
parallel with a server implementation
that's pretty good benefit right there
now you don't have to wait for the
server to get stood up before you can do
it your to begin to build your client it
also is a good way to just sort of put
it through its paces as you're in the
design phase or say you're like a
financial services company and you don't
want your developers making live
requests to your actual production
backends you could attach that to a mock
and have them send requests without
using real money
it more sophisticated of course would be
to have a parallel system that didn't
use real money but this is a good way to
start specs can also power test
generation here is a snapshot of project
from a colleague of mine Noah Dietz is a
project called oats which is open API
test templates these are ways in which
you can make assertions and run
automated tests that help keep your API
specification in line with what you're
actually doing
it's pretty neat I encourage you to
check it out you could use
specifications to classify traffic at
runtime or to validate payloads at
runtime I mentioned earlier generating
SDKs for clients or to do server-side
code there there's a lot that specs to
you but given that this talks about API
design and how that open API influences
it and its opinions um I want to really
talk about this so this is the spec
editor in a PG edge but you've probably
seen lots of these out in the wild you
know as you incorporate specifications
early in your process you get better API
I'm going to talk about this a lot more
for the rest of the for the rest of the
talk but being able to design and see
your API so when I go back to 2014 when
we started the working group for swagger
to you know people didn't actually
understand at the time why having a
yellow-based syntax mattered and it
mattered so that we could do things like
this like the ability to write in a web
browser a specification that's a big
deal and the ability is getting
real-time documentation this is like
documentation driven development and
it's it's a way in which you can make
better api's before you even written a
line of code so before we go into the
open API influence on API design I want
to review some of key API design
principles that we will then apply to
that and bring it all together to
anybody read this book it's been out for
a while I see a few hands good I would
encourage you to look you can find this
on our website
calm even though was published in 2012
it continues to be really relevant it's
been cited by organizations like the
White House gov in the Obama years it it
continues to influence a lot of thinking
and it's a pretty simple pragmatic
approach to building interfaces that
developers love and a number of the
examples that I'm going to pull come
from this and this was really gathered
from the collecting the patterns that we
were seeing that we're working with our
customers and working out in the wild
and then synthesizing that down so it's
an evidence-based approach to API design
and therefore patterns from this that I
want to call out today if you want more
please read the book but you know one
don't reuse reuse don't reinvent obvious
again these are all basically
common-sense applied to that's all
design is really just common sense and
creativity to resource oriented and when
I say that I mean the are and URL I'm
three I'm going to talk about names and
why they are so critically important in
this area and then for just a general
principle when in doubt do what's best
for developers and by that I mean your
consumers so reuse don't reinvent web
technologies when we talk about Web API
design for me the first Web API that I
saw and fell in love with was Twitter
sometime in 2007 I would say and what
was amazing to me about Twitter was that
I understood how to use their web
service I mean the actual website and
use Twitter as as a user of their web
interface but he switching from that to
their API was really easy back then you
could use your basic authentication the
same credentials you're using to sign in
to the site you would use to sign your
requests and the way they'd organized
their API was very similar in its
hierarchy to how their website had been
designed them that's not an accident and
so it was so amazing and beautiful to me
that I could be get at my data not just
in the way that they said I could but in
the way that I wanted to do and a lot of
what made the web work is what makes Web
API is work
- right so JSON JavaScript is the lingua
franca of the web
it it is why JSON emerged as a rival and
successor to XML so JSON is a key piece
of web api is and and HTTP is is another
great thing we if you think back to
right before this style of JSON over
HTTP came out everyone's doing over PC
more or less and that's perfectly fine
it just wasn't leveraging what is really
great about the web
it was tunneling a bunch of things like
the actions through the payload and by
using what makes HTTP and the web great
we had we got web api's and that's
important enough to call out they are
and resource oriented so if you use the
web you understand that things have
locations and this is why I was so easy
for me when I first got into API is in
Web API through Twitter he was because I
already understood how the weblog worked
I knew that oh you go to a blog and then
their posts and then posts or entities
this is kind of hierarchy was reflected
in a good URL design and it just makes
it easy to think about how the site
works and how to take the context of the
service and apply it to how you access
its data it's tremendously powerful you
don't have to teach the basic mechanisms
of accessing data and functionality in
the last the fourth I was this third
this is third actually naming so it was
my favorite quotes and computer science
for by Phil Carleton there are only two
hard things in computer science cache
and validation and naming things there's
a take on this there's a version of this
is goes it wasn't from Phil but
apologies to Phil that there were three
sorry there are two hard problems in
computer science cache invalidation
naming things and off-by-one errors but
but naming it think I hard it is to
create a good user interface that's a UI
right it takes a lot of design and
rework even before you write a line of
code api's are no different than that so
all you have is URL safe characters
really to deal with when you're working
with your resource design that means
this means that the names of things have
really great power and one of things I
like to do in API design is to involve
my tech writers
because you really want people who who
actually care and think about words a
lot and so not only do tech writers
spend a lot of time trying to think
about how to break complicated things
down to make them easy for people who
are approaching a subject area but they
also tend to know a lot about other
parts of your API and so they can help
you keep your API consistent and then
the third bit is what I just alluded to
a a minute ago is that they care about
words and coming up with the right name
of thing think about how hard it is to
name a variable well right that's hard
um and when you're doing this for me
anybody here play Adventureland resort
text-based I would dating myself here Oh
No Wow anyway um I don't time to do a
demo of that but if you're familiar with
it you know it was a you were in a room
you see a lamp on a table you say get
lamp and to me that's what I'm building
in a when I'm designing an API I'm
thinking about that how do I make it
obvious from these words how you work
with this system and so uh you know if
you the way I think about it is that
you're developers are taking a journey
through your API that's not unlike
gazook and all you have to work with
with text and it's your job to keep them
from being eaten by a grue I have to be
a funnier joke if you don't plead God
anyway so you have one job that the
api's job is to make the developer as
successful as possible the orientation
for API is to think about design choices
from the application developers point of
view if you look in the lower right hand
corner this little blue section this is
a Japanese expression of Asha and I
apologize if I'm saying it poorly
annulled speak Japanese but Shoshanna
it's the it's a concept of the
beginner's mind it's a Zen concept
um so the example I like to give here is
uh who knows what I am ee I stands for
Wow
I expected more telco people in the
audience today it's the International
Mobile Equipment Identity if you look in
your phone settings you'll probably see
your IMEI number when I saw my first
telco based API I thought what's bad
it's a device ID right and it's the
telco it's that curse of knowledge that
you have and it's really hard
to step outside of and that's why taking
API design to other people is really
important specifically API people who
are possible developers outside your
organization and understand how they see
the words that you've chosen because it
is difficult to avoid the bad ones so
the developer the beginner's mind is is
another place I like to go when
designing api's all right so now that
we've touched on specifications why they
matter why open API is important and
basic API design principles we can put
them all together but as I started with
just remember open api is not going to
magically make your api awesome right it
but it does have some opinions and I
find it's a whole lot easier to work
with them to then to fight them and this
matters whether you were building micro
services or whether you're building
full-blown public API programs so in the
rest of this talk we'll cover and I'll
make sure there's time for questions
we'll cover this these six ways that
open API guides API design 1 JSON will
use JSON schema you'll see why that
matters in a second I'm gonna walk you
through each of these in detail two
signatures why they're what how the
signature mechanism works an open API
and why that's important three warning
do not vary your response models from
parameters for collections and entities
are a nice pattern and a good fit that's
from the API design key book that I
mentioned earlier five versioning and
how you can approach it with open API
and six defaults and pagination
so open API leverages JSON schema and it
was in a draft at the time that we
launched a v3 it's dense in fact we were
a little worried that it it was a dead
end of a specification but it's it's had
a lot of it's been revived a lot
recently and so but we we picked a draft
and we can't just update it without
breaking things that's why when I talked
about the big list of possibilities it's
on there but we didn't take JSON schema
entirely as is and well one difference
between version 2 and version 3 is that
we added we added any of an and one of
two that I've been a common request but
what's important to remember and one of
the challenges you face in working with
open api is that really jason schema is
a validation language and not a modeling
language and if you remember that it
will help you on your on your journey to
anyone recognize this when I think of
the signature that you know it's John
Hancock's the one is the one that
springs to mind that big one in the
center but if you really closely you can
see that a path and verb this is some
lot people don't realize that open api
also sign the Declaration of
Independence it's not true but you know
that it is a unique unique pairing of a
path and a verb that really defines the
core of what's in an open API spec that
is its signature and what I mean by that
is that if I'm a gateway and there's
traffic passing through then I should be
able to identify based on what I know
from the specification which operation
it maps on to in that spec that's the
signature mechanism and you'll see I
mean I kind of cheated the plus
media-type I didn't let them sign but uh
the the media type if you are going to
have multiple media types you can use
that as a way to it's a it's the next
layer of signature but I'm path and for
it just if you think in terms of path
and verb it will help
number two don't vary response models by
parameter so I'm tried to protect the
guy shouldn't say guilty I mean this API
a came about I think around 2006 so it
predates a lot of things but you can see
that what we have here is where is it in
the method I put in red could the method
equals right it is um
you were passing in what the signature
is in the query string and because that
can appear anywhere in the query string
it can be a lot harder to figure out
which what the signature mechanism is if
you're in a layered system like a proxy
and that the when we're next set out to
build their own stack for api's they
wanted to have a nice clean signature
magnetism and that's why we have the
legacy that we have today of path and
verb and that's a perfectly good way to
do things I mean that's basically the
way the web works so just a warning
don't vary response models by parameters
it's funny this is one of the things
that comes up a lot in the community
requests for how the next edition of the
spec should go and we continue to resist
it in part because it adds another kind
of burden on tooling authors as I said
before three I think we're up to you
collections and entities and so what I
mean by this is you know like slash dogs
or this could be slash posts right that
is the collection and then you've got
this specific entity there so if I've
got slash dogs and I do a post to slash
dog so I'm creating a new dog entity and
I will get back a unique ID that defines
that and that specific dog entity and
then I can do things like update it or
delete it or get it right and so
collections and entities are a really
nice way to represent the hierarchy of
your system and it's a way in which you
can use the names of those entities to
help people understand how to work with
your API s it's also useful for API
management right because now I can
because I got the signature mechanism
and because because I've got this way in
which I can think about the structure
hierarchically I can then apply policies
to specific areas like say I want to
throttle
I mean throttle and dogs is the wrong
word to put together but anyway say I
want to throttle dogs
for but not cats right I could decide to
do that because I have these kinds of
sign I think I need a better example
than that next time so sorry Peter
another useful thing that approached you
to mention during during the naming bit
is the singleton resource so imagine
this was users and users one two three
four happened to be me having a slash me
and I forget who pioneered that it was
early Facebook was early on that pattern
but it's nice to have these convenience
singleton methods that map onto these
things and you can still apply policies
in the same way to that versioning
nothing causes more controversy in API
design than versioning and I'm here to
give you permission to do versioning the
way you think is right for you however
do you think what's best for your
developers I remember when Facebook used
and hopefully they don't do this anymore
but you used to be able to pass in the
version you wanted in the query string
and people always forgot to do that and
things would break the the downside of
versioning in the resource is that it
feels kind of wrong to version the
resource but it's also obvious and so
you have to figure out what's right for
elvers and make that trade-off but what
I want to talk about is the way in which
open API has opinions here so one of the
things we added in the version 3 of the
specification is the servers replace the
host and we added a way in which to
template eyes that server so you can in
fact put serve in your servers
information you could put the version
used to be able to do that with a base
URL now you can do in the servers as
well the only caveat I would give here
and think something to be careful of is
that it may be that you want a separate
specification if you're putting versions
in your servers you might as well think
of those as different contracts because
someday you're going to retire one of
them so um but you know if you choose to
do the Twilio style they if I member
correctly to Leo's got at least 60 it's
probably like a hundred now but they
have a lot of versions that they keep
and and that works for them and they
they use a date based format to do that
so I give you permission to use it works
for you but do look at what's worked for
other people
defaults and pagination again I think
this comes back to naming pick good make
good choices and how you name things we
took a look around and saw a bunch of
patterns I think my least favorite was
Twitter's at the time it was RPP which
did four requests per page and that's
just not it's not intuitive right limit
and offset are nice because database
people who use databases are familiar
this is common language but with open
API at least a what I really want is a
consistent way to apply pagination to
all of my collections and the ability to
define that in one spot and reuse that
definition over and over again is really
important the pagination is actually a
great place to use hyper media to I
think it's the most obvious case for
hyper media if you can give people back
a link to the next page of results
consider doing that and you should be
able to do those kinds of things using
an open API um so here your three
takeaways and I'm gonna open this up to
some questions
one investing in IP in API design it
always pays benefits it's so much easier
to make a change early in that process
and to do it later we all know this and
yet we continue to push it off and not
do it properly investing API design
using even using it specifications to
help that process go better to the
promise of specs by having a formal
machine friendly description of your
services you will do less work overtime
levering expensive specifications
throughout the lifecycle will help you
do less work yeah and the third bit is
don't fight open API as opinions if
you're going down the open API route
hopefully have a better understanding of
some of the ways in which it sees the
world I'm gonna add a number four which
is please call it open API it's
important for the standard
[Music]